foreign
[Music]
I'm a professor at MIT I'm in the
department of biological engineering and
my lab is in the Koch Institute for
Integrative cancer research
um broadly my lab is interested in
developing uh new instrumentation uh for
cancer research and outside as well
other types of areas of life science
that mostly focused on cancer
and we do that primarily by developing
new approaches for measuring biophysical
properties of single cells and we have
ways to do this with very high Precision
that I will show you in my presentation
so the quantity that we have been
measuring from single cells that we do
really well is mass we can actually
weigh single cells with just this
incredible Precision then I want to give
you some context for this so the ability
to weigh things it's been of interest to
physicists and electrical engineers for
for quite some time and there's really
two things that have made this
attractive uh as a as a fundamental
measurement one is that the well so
first let me explain what you're looking
at here in this picture what you're
seeing is it almost looks like these
little overpasses connecting
um these two side regions and those are
suspended Bridges you could almost think
of them like a guitar string a very
short string and those things if you
shake them at the resonant frequency
will vibrate
um and if you uh put math on those
things the frequency will change in
proportion to how much mass you put on
it now people in the area of electrical
engineering and physics have been able
to make these things incredibly small
this is really the area of
nanotechnology and the smaller you make
these things the less they weigh and the
smaller amounts of mass that you can you
could actually discern so nanotechnology
has allowed people to make these very
very small resonators number two is that
electrical engineers have figured out
how to measure frequency with just this
incredible Precision down to about one
very close to one part per billion so
you take this small object that you've
made this vibrating guitar string you
divide this by a number close to a
billion that tells you how small of a
mass that you can measure
um and so this has been
um kind of a race over the years to push
the limits down further and further and
actually the the record now um is at the
level of the yacht programs uh so what
we're talking about here is individual
gold atoms that bind to this guitar like
strings changes the frequency enough
that could be measured and detected
but what we're interested in is in in
the area of life science and there you
have to do this underwater and all this
work has been done in vacuum and it's
needed to be done in vacuum so that
these uh these resonators can vibrate um
with just a really high degree um of of
um Fidelity like the high Crystal high
quality wine Crystal but if you actually
take this underwater this situation
completely changes a viscous damping
that makes the frequency resolution just
go down by orders of magnitude and so
what you're left with when it comes to
bring this underwater the limits have
really been around a nanogram so far far
away from this level of individual cold
atoms and to kind of put that in
perspective the weight of a mammalian
cell is is about that it's fairly enough
to weigh a large size mammalian cell
much less be able to look at small
changes in it so what my lab did
um a number of years is we took this
idea of of a resonator in this case I'm
showing one that's in the shape of a
cantilever uh where math binds and
changes the frequency and we made it
Hollow we actually put fluid inside of
it um and so we got rid of the outside
viscous drag from this and then we can
flow cells inside of the cantilever and
measure frequencies as we do that and
this turned out to improve
um the detection limit by six orders of
magnitude it took us from nanograms to
femphrograms so now also not only could
we weigh a cell but we could look at
very very minute changes in how much a
cell weighs and this has had really big
implications that I will show you in
terms of being able to read out
fundamental properties of cells and
their environment and how they respond
to drugs
um but first I'll just show you that
these devices we've uh have been working
on for many years to to fabricate them
um they're actually uh within a vacuum
package that's that's on the chip so
these things are made on uh eight inch
Wafers um up in the top left corner and
each uh chip now if you go to the middle
pictures the size of a postage stamp and
if you zoom into those you can see the
little diving board there you can't see
the uh Channel inside because it's
sandwiched in Silicon but that's
vibrating in a vacuum cavity and you can
see little electrode contacts above that
we use to make contact to it
um to be able to measure
um its its frequency
so here is a little bit more closely
showing you how this works so this thing
is is vibrating with flow cells one one
by one through them very similar to
where a flow cytometer works that little
uh dip downward and the frequency is how
much the cell weighs in the solution
that it's in so we actually call that
the buoyant mass of the cell
um if the cell had the same density as
the solution it would not be there would
not be a signal bear so it's really it's
how much a cell weighs in the solution
that it's in and so to give you an idea
of a Precision what we're doing in this
experiment is we're taking the same cell
and we're flowing it back and forth
um by controlling the pressures uh
through this cantilever
and each time we measure the height of
the peak and we plot that that's a point
on this on this plot here and so this
gives you an idea of the scale so one
picogram of Mass is like a 75 nanometer
uh increase of the cell this is a mouse
lymphoblast
um and and if we look at our noise level
so our noise level uh puts us at less
than 50 femphograms or 0.1 percent of
the cell mass is what we can discern
and so in terms of position that
corresponds to the cell changing its
diameter by about five nanometers so
that's what we could actually resolve
with this so this is more precise and
even really Advanced forms of microscopy
can do by looking at these very small
changes of frequency of this device that
we can measure just with this High
degree of precision
now over the years we've been able to
show that this device can measure more
than just mass for example
um in this recent work that I'll tell
you a little bit about uh pretty soon we
we can excite acoustic waves within this
device that actually probe the mechanics
of the cell it changes the fluids in
such a way that it perturbs itself by
very just tens of nanometers and
squishes them in and out and we can
measure the stiffness of the cell uh
from doing this in a very non-invasive
way and very high throughput way so
that's that's one example
another one is that we could actually
measure the density of the cell and we
can measure its molecular composition by
weighing the cell in different fluids
and from there directly calculating
essentially the dry density of the cell
that the the total density of the cell
uh and the dry Mass so we could get a
lot more very fundamental parameters
about the cell from doing this
we can also take the same cell and weigh
it multiple times kind of like I showed
you in the slide before but we have
devices where they can flow through and
get weighed multiple times at one pass
as they flow through and we call the
output from this Mass accumulation rate
um and then with with
methods that you see here we have the
ability to take cells off the chip uh
put them in weld uh and Link each well
to what we measured before whether it be
the growth rates here the acoustic
scattering density whatever we have and
and then this is compatible with down uh
Downstream
single cell rna-seq so we can actually
link these biophysical properties to the
transcriptome of the cell or any other
single cell Downstream assay that you
would like to perform
okay so let me tell you now some of the
applications that this has got us into
um so first I want to go to bacteria and
so we're taking this device now that
we've made where we have strung together
several of these resonators and one long
fluidic channel so cell comes in and
gets it's weighed several times as it
travels through this this here is a
trajectory of one cell that you're
seeing in this green here and if we zoom
into that you can see there are several
points from each wing of one of those
devices now that's one E coli traveling
through we can take the slope of that
and that is the what we call the mass
accumulation rate or the mar now we can
plot that and we can flow many of them
through at once and you can see the
individual Mass accumulation rates of
these E coli now watch what happens when
we put a drug into this so below now at
time equals around 80 minutes we are
putting an antibiotic into here called
canomyosin and immediately following
there you can see the slopes start to
reduce
um and become flat and the mass
ultimately goes down too if you look
towards the right around 140 minutes you
can see the mass is clustered at a lower
level
so there's there's a few important
implications from this one is that we're
looking at the response of this
antibiotic and we're seeing it on time
scale tens of minutes and so by having
this High Precision of mass this really
translates to the ability to have a very
rapid readout for drug response
um much quicker than it would take if we
wanted to use a conventional way which
looks at proliferation and essentially
use light scattering to shine that
through a collection of bacteria and as
they stop dividing as frequently you can
read that out in the way the intensity
of the light is scattering through in
this case since we're measuring
individual cells with this Precision we
could see this much earlier on and it
turns out that has huge implications for
being able to make what's called a rapid
antibiotic susceptibility test right now
these tests take several days to do and
and in the itu that has huge
ramifications and what I'll show you is
that these can actually reduce that time
down by a factor of three
and then second these are single cells
so we actually see the heterogeneity you
can actually see differences across
different cells at one given time Point
some cells change their slope a lot and
some a little bit so we get this look
into the heterogeneity of growth rates
across cells and then finally all this
is done without consuming many cells so
we can take small number of cells to
make these measurements again for
practical applications like antibiotic
susceptibility testing one of the
reasons why this takes so long on the
clinic is that you have to grow up
enough bacteria that you can scatter
light through it and see something but
in this case we can make measurements in
very small numbers of bacteria
um and so I won't go too into the too
much into the details of this but I will
say um that I co-founded a company so uh
as full disclosure I'm a co-founder of
affinity biosensors and and have Equity
interest in the company but but I will
show you here that they have made this
uh this um this instrument kind of a
desktop instrument to do these rapid
antibiotic susceptibility testing and
inside there you can see is you load in
a 96 well plate that has the drugs
pre-loaded and then it's read out kind
of well by well and what you're seeing
here in that plot is how and about uh in
this case several hours you can start to
detect the growth of bugs and some wells
but not in others
um to actually read this out and so this
company has submitted to the FDA what's
called a 510k clearance last summer
um and with that being approved this
could actually then be used in hospitals
to return results directly to to
patients so we're very excited about
this development
okay so I'm going to change now to a
different application that we've been
pursuing so we're going to move from
infectious diseases um to cancer
and unlike infectious disease like
bacteria-based ones where you can do
very clear tests to know which drug is
best for the patient by directly testing
the bugs the drugs on the bacteria from
the patient for cancer it's actually
really different
um and in fact for for most cancers in
most patients the drug ultimately ends
up being chosen empirically now there
are some cases where there are
biomarkers that can guide this and in
those cases it's really done based on
genomics based on sequencing genomic
profiling of the patient and that has
been the most successful approach in the
clinic to be able to match patients to
to a drug
but the problem with it is that for many
patients uh when they sequence there are
mutations that are actionable in other
words mutations that that tell the
physician that this is a drug to use in
fact in the bottom right here these are
results from a recent study and out of
5540 patients that come in only about 12
percent were actually able to get
prescribed drug uh based on their
sequencing information so this is a very
powerful technique it's the best thing
now in the clinic for guiding therapy
but for most patients it's not
accessible
um and so this is something that we're
we're interested in and and changing to
have uh assays that can be complementary
to the sequencing to to widen out the
number of patients that could have um
therapies uh chosen for them in an
effective way
and so one approach for this is called
functional Precision medicine the idea
is you actually take tumor cells from
the patient
um you take them X Vivo and you
challenge them with different drugs uh
and then you look to see how those cells
respond to the drugs you measure the X
Vivo drug response and based on that
then you make a selection in this case
the green drug for that specific patient
now this is an idea that several decades
old
uh and it really hasn't worked out so
well because it turns out that um cancer
cells are more complicated than bacteria
and the drugs don't always have the same
efficacy and so what you're seeing on
this slide is what's been done for
bacteria but as it is now has not worked
so well for cancer cells
um but over the past five to ten years
or so
um there there has been a number of labs
that have re-entered this field
including my own
um kind of a Resurgence of this to
attack this in a new way
um that that um is showing promise to go
beyond what had been done before where
essentially the cancer cells were just
plated on a dish and kind of treated in
a very simplistic way so let me show you
there are two strategies now um that are
being pursued um to to address this
problem
okay so one is you think about a
different patient you just associate it
and then you actually see it as
organoids and you grow it up into into
more complex structures and they're just
plating these cells on that plate
and the um the ability to make
um better and better organoids has
really progressed a lot over these years
the idea is that that can more
Faithfully replicate the tumor micro
environment but still with this approach
a major challenge is
um that you need to be able to engineer
at the tumor microenvironment um to
maintain the same cell state that it was
in the tumor but this is an area that a
lot of many research groups have made
significant progress on and is starting
to become a possibility now and then you
have the ability to do extensive drug
testing on all these cells that you then
have essentially grown up
to not only think about selecting drugs
but to be able to find mechanisms for
resistance as well
now one downside of this approach is it
takes a while it could take several
weeks and sometimes a month or more to
make this material and that's not always
clinically actionable to have to wait
that amount of time so a separate
strategy is what's called acute drug
sensitivity testing and so you take them
much earlier on before you even really
proliferate these cells
um so they've had minimal drift in the
cell State
um and you challenge them there and so
they're the advantages you actually can
return results rapidly to the patient
within days which based on many
discussions we've had with oncologists
um really makes a big difference but
they're the challenges you need to have
early indicators of drug sensitivity if
you just simply try to measure
proliferation like has been done for
bacteria that doesn't always work
because the cells are kind of on a race
to death
um even if they haven't seen the drug in
this early State many of them are gone
um and so you need to have readouts of
the cell that can tell you what the drug
response is so that's what I wanted to
talk about next
so I'll show you one example of how
we've been using math
um to do this
um and so this is a collaboration that
I've had for quite some time with Keith
Keith Ligon in his lab
um at Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and
what we did in this study is that key
slab is able to generate organoids from
glioblastoma patients and we took 69 of
these patient-derived models that you
see here
um and we challenge them with a drug
called TMZ this is a standard of care
that almost not all but many patients
will get that have glioblastoma brain
cancer and we then took a control set of
cells and and gave them um a control
with DMSO drug
we then took those uh two different
samples we disassociated the cells into
single cells we weighed them um with
this cantilever structure that I showed
you and we measure the distribution of
those cells now we're kind of at the
bottom left there and what we found in
the study is that patients who were
responsive
um to TMZ their Mass distribution of the
drug-created cells were different than
the control whereas What patients that
did not have a response uh whether
they're drug treatment or not they're
Mass distribution were identical this
you can see that in the bottom histogram
there
and so what we did what was very unique
in the study is that we had patient
outcomes we knew overall survival for
each one of those patients so we asked
the question
does this shift in Mass distribution
that we see does that predict overall
survivability and what we found is it
did
um and so that was very exciting for us
and this happens to be one cancer where
there is a biomarker based on sequencing
sequencing that's called MGMT promoter
methylation and we did as well as that
biomarker but the the message from this
is that if it works here perhaps it
could work for other cancers where there
does not exist the sequencing based
marker and that's a very active area of
our lab right now
okay so I want to go on to talk about a
different area here um is and this is
immune cells so as some of you might be
familiar with a lot of the new exciting
drugs developed recently are aimed at
um really improving uh the ability of
the immune cells to Target the tumor and
immune cells are something that we've
been able to also make very precise
measurements of so what I'm showing you
here these are T cells that we have
taken uh from from human and we've
activated them X Vivo and what we're
plotting here is the mass of each cell
uh on the x-axis and the y-axis is this
Mass accumulation rate is the mar and
you can see at T equals zero these are
mostly resting T cells that are just
kind of sitting there they're very small
um they're mostly just a nucleus they
haven't really had a chance to grow yet
but over time once they have had this
activation signal you can see that start
to get bigger and I start to slowly
accumulate mass at the 12 hours
now at 24 hours you can see they've
gotten bigger and are accelerating more
in their growth and by 36 hours you see
kind of there's a spectrum of of mass
sizes here and at this point they're
starting to blast they're growing and
dividing so we've been able to have a
very precise way to follow the
activation of T cells by their mass and
so one of the areas now that we're we're
looking into is to what extent could
this information tell us about
um
about the performance of the T-cell
activation
um and any dysfunction in the T Cell
itself these are very preliminary
results
um that I'll show you
um but what we're looking at here
um are these are from patients these are
severe T Cell dysfunction uh in CLL
chronic lymphocytic leukemia
um and what we are able to see on the
left actually is if we compare these CLL
samples in red they actually have a
different Mass distribution than the
healthy counterpart and when we activate
them their ability to accumulate Mass
which is shown on the right is also
different that can accumulate Mass quite
as well
so we're very interested to use this
generally to look at dysfunction and T
cells and to look at how amino
checkpoint blockade therapies will alter
the ability of these T cell size
distributions or mass distributions that
we can detect and really ask the
question can we be able to predict
um how a patient is going to respond to
one of these immunotherapies by looking
at these T Cell Mass based measurements
so finally I'll just show you
um that I have co-founded a company
called travera again at full disclosure
uh equity on the equity owner in this
company
um and what you're looking at here is a
room full of 24 of these instruments
that I've been showing you results from
and these are now in a CLIA lab so the
lab has been approved so that it can
actually now return results to an
oncologist and the results can be shared
with the patient
um and so the way this LAB Works is
typically around 5000 cells per drug can
be tested
um 30 minutes uh for for um for drug to
test and what's really important here is
a two-day turnaround
um and so now
um the the main goal is to figure out to
what extent can this predict patient
outcome um and so this there are
clinical studies now being run on these
systems to be able to answer that
question
so I want to tell you more I want to
tell you now how we can get additional
information from these cells besides
just their mass and so what I'm showing
you here is is how we could actually
measure the density of cells
um so here what I'm plotting is the
buoyant mass as a function of fluid
density and look what happens if we
weigh the cell in a different density so
in green here
um the the fluid is in is purple so the
density is 1.1 the cell actually floats
here and you take that measurement you
connect those lines The Intercept is the
density of the cell uh the um intercept
of the y-axis is the total mass now if
we weigh the cell also in heavy water
and so this is deuterated water that
exchanges very rapidly throughout the
cell we're essentially weighing the dry
material and it sinks like before but
not quite as much
this tells us the dry density which is
purely based on the material composition
of the cell and the dry Mass so by
weighing these different fluids we can
gain quite a bit of more information
about the cell
so I'll show you just a couple of things
that are interesting first I should show
you how do we exchange these fluids um
so here here's how we do it I'm going to
play a movie to show you
so the cell goes through its weight in
one fluid and then the higher density
fluid say is in yellow and now the cell
returns in this higher density fluid and
so that way by following the cell once
in one fluid and then returning it in
the other we can get two measurements of
that cell and two different fluids
um so I'll show you what this what this
looks like
so we're plotting here the mass versus
volume of cells that we measured this
way so these are this is from a cell
line um the bottom left there are cells
that just divided in the top right are
ones that are about to divide but look
what happens when we plot now the
density of the cell as a function of its
mass
you can see that the density is very
tightly conserved actually so if you
actually look at those numbers the
coefficient of variance of density is
almost two orders of magnitude smaller
than Mass
and so it cells it turns out are very
tightly regulating their density and
that has made it a really interesting
biomarker to look at because that
regulation changes when you perturb the
cell and I'll show you an example
so these are cells that we've treated
with storosporin it's a very strong drug
it's a broad spectrum kinase inhibitor
but this is to illustrate a point and
when we treat these cells for just
actually a few hours of this drug what
you see here is that there's drastic
change in density turns out this is just
because of water content the cells are
getting rid of a lot of water and it
makes them more dense I mean you can see
the density shoots up their buoyant Mass
hasn't changed at all actually but the
water content has
um here's another example
um
you're okay so same thing here we're
plotting it versus volume so you can see
there is a shift in volume because the
cells have have gotten rated with some
water
um okay so let me show you one other
drug here this is uh rapamycin uh that
targets mtor it's an mtor inhibitor uh
that's that's critical to growth and
nutrient sensing Pathways and here the
effects are more subtle so you can see
in red are the cells that have have been
treated with uh this mtor inhibitor
rapamycin and so their density has
changed
um and if we look at this so what we're
seeing here is this is actually the
equation for buoyant Mass
so there's some change in density
um but there's also um change in the
material properties that the composition
of the cells that have contributed to
this
um and so this is another kind of way to
see that with density we can see very
subtle changes in this case that would
be difficult to see by just mass or
volume alone
okay so the last part of the talk I
wanted to move on to to what will be the
third and last application here and I'm
calling this targeting minimal residual
disease in cancer so mrd this is the
idea that you treat a patient and
particularly with blood-based Cancers a
lot of these drugs are so effective that
99.99 of the of the tumor cells are
limited but there's a small small amount
that remain that can turn out
um in many cases to cause relapse of the
patient and then the tumor grows out
and and so we're very interested in
being able to extract these mrd cells um
from a patient and be able to run drug
tests on them but it actually turns out
it's not an easy problem to get these
mrd cells
um the the markers for these cells uh
are not perfect uh that in both in terms
of specificity and selectivity and we
are very interested in asking the
question if the biophysical properties
can be used as a way to enrich for these
cells and that's kind of evidence for
that
um I'm going to show you what a
pathologist would see so what
Pathologists see and here you're looking
at these images here these are lymphoma
cells and they have abnormal shapes so
as microscopy is currently used in the
clinic
um you can see these sorts of shapes and
that's what tells an oncologist how to
describe um what's happening but what I
wanted to try to tell you is that the
microscope reveals say the size or the
shape of the cells but the size uh
biophysically is related to its mass and
it turns out that its shape in many ways
is related to the cortex stiffness of
the cell so what is the cortex of the
cell
so the cortex of the cell is schematized
here it's the outermost layer of the
cell that includes actin filaments and
myosin and when
um when the properties of that cortex
change
um it changes the shape of the cells
um and in many types of cancer cells um
that is that cortex is is affected
um and so we are looking at ways then to
measure the stiffness in addition to
mass and these other properties I showed
you and at the very beginning of the
talk I I introduced this device for
acoustic scattering and that's what I'm
showing you here there's not enough time
to explain fully how it works but we
publish it but the main thing is that
this device vibrates in such a way to
create very subtle fluid flows that
actually cause the cell to deform and
when the cell deforms
um the degree to which it deforms
changes the effective stiffness of that
whole cantilever which then affects its
vibrational frequency at a point that's
independent from the mass again
um it's we describe this in the paper I
just wanted to kind of give you a sense
of of what we can do and so we can now
measure the mass and stiffness
simultaneously from that same cell
and so
um this is an example that that proves
this we're treating the cells of
electronsulin which disrupts the actin
filaments and the cortex and we can see
the stiffness in our signal changes in
response to that and we can also see
microscopically that the cortex is
getting perturbed by uh by this drug
um and so a lot of the work that we're
thinking about now in the lab is to
validate these types of markers and to
do that we really need to be able to
take from the same cell the biophysical
properties that we measure but also how
the transcriptome of that cell um as
well
um to be able to to really have full
validation and so this is work that's
ongoing
um but I can tell you that we as I
mentioned earlier we have the way to
collect these cells and then do single
cell rnac from them
um and we've done some of this already
based on Cell lines but we're now doing
it this on clinical samples um that have
a much higher degree of complexity than
these simple proliferating cell lines
and we have developed um the way now to
be able to
um take these cells from the device and
run them through a Sorter and collect
them actually very much like a flow
cytometer and bend them so that not only
single cell measurements so we can take
bins of these cells into bulk rna-c on
different fractions sorted biophysically
um and so that's something also that we
have recently been able to show and I'll
just give you an example
um this is from a mantle cell lymphoma
patient sample
um these are normal lymphocytes but if
we look at the tumor cells superimposed
when we're plotting the stiffness versus
the mass we see some very interesting
structure that is not the same uh of
what we see from the normal cells and so
you can imagine if this green box here
we can take those cells and look at
their transcriptomes and and really see
um if we can validate those as
particular types of mrd cells we could
have a way to go and enrich for them
okay so let me conclude with kind of a
few key points here
um what we really believe is combining
these biophysical markers that I focused
on here but also with flow based markers
um together that you can have the
potential to enrich uh for cells that
would be really hard to do with either
one alone
another
um key Point here is that Excel drug
sensitivity testing assays they have the
ability to go beyond what genomics can
do because they're integrative assays in
terms of how the whole cell is
responding to the drug but they've been
challenging for many reasons and in the
case of mrd because these cells are very
sparse and can rapidly deteriorate or
reprogram when removed from the patient
um but the ability to make these high
Precision measurements uh enables you to
do acute testing on time scales that
don't don't require proliferation and
can minimize the amount of phenotypic
drift um that the cells could go through
maximizing the chance of the readout
being able to be predictive of response
of the patient
so that concludes my talk and I will
just acknowledge that there are there I
have been able to work with just an
incredible team at the coke Institute as
well as Dana Farber in several different
Labs on this work
um as well as funding sources from the
NIH as well as this Center for precision
cancer medicine in the Ludwig Center at
MIT
um so thank you very much and I will
stop there